[Music]
okay i have this
crazy story of this egyptian fisherman
who nearly lost his life when he
was fishing so he said that he had like
multiple lines set up and
on one line he caught a fish he was like
oh tight
but then another lion got another fish
and so he didn't know what to do with
this fish
so this will put it in his mouth to try
to get the other fish [ __ ]
he didn't have a basket did you catching
goldfish the [ __ ]
how small are these fish you'll see in a
second he's gonna get ripped out of his
mouth
so he put the fish in his mouth and he
tried to get the other fish and in the
meantime he did that
the fish swam down his sleeves actually
in there oh [ __ ] yeah oh he's holding
the not the fishing pole in his mouth
that's why i was like oh i thought he
was talking about the fishing line
yeah that's what i thought no no no the
fish so i imagine like a fish head is in
his mouth and it's like
[ __ ] tail slapping them yeah and he
just deep throat a fish
he could have put the fish down into the
boat but he was like i'm gonna hold it
maybe he didn't have like a basket or
something that's a savage ass dude
i know this sounds like one of those
stories you hear about as a kid like not
to be too greedy
you know like those fables or whatever
oh yeah put the fish down you hear the
story about the egyptian fishermen who
could deep throat fishes
[Laughter]
the only thing i heard about when i was
a kid is uh like you have to sleep with
like things in your ear the roaches will
go in your yeah
that happened that's true my grandma
does [ __ ] put cotton yeah well when
you grow up now you live in a bad area
whatever you know low housing though
there's roaches
on and they go in your ear spiders so
like like one of my cousins
like my uncle he had to get it out and
you get a cigar and you blow the smoke
and the roach and the roach comes out of
here
oh [ __ ] it'll bury itself in there like
a baby roach
baby roaches dog not those big ones
those little brown ones
and those things multiply oh where are
they sleeping next to like the wall
so that it goes right into it so in the
bed dog you're just in the hood dog
yeah little baby roaches in first grade
i think it was first or second grade
she missed school for like i forgot how
long but she missed some school and then
when she came back she told us that the
reason why she missed school is because
they found spider eggs in her ear that's
a story you always hear of as a kid
you're like no what yes she's not
supposed to say that
though just lie don't tell the kids the
truth
yeah yeah don't tell the kids at school
that huh like your spider ear hey spider
ear
like oh [ __ ] that we didn't make fun of
her she was nice she's saying
beautifully really she was known to be
like a very nice singer
in that in the school but anyway back to
this guy so
um i'm going to show you the photos so
he went to the hospital
oh what they took they like surgically
took out the [ __ ]
why couldn't it die like it did die but
it got stuck
like like in the esophagus no in his
throat oh so like
it it did he put that big old fish in
his mouth no
so they said that it went into his
throat but it left enough space in there
so the man didn't die
like he was walking around town with the
[ __ ] tail flapping out of his mouth
i'm pretty sure the fish died how come
he can't
pull it out the gills might be all those
spines you see the spine on the oh yeah
did he ask if it's cool if they wash it
so he could keep it and sell it
i hope he did i hope he didn't when i
thought of an egyptian i thought like
those paintings
and this was like on a [ __ ] reed boat
and he's like butt naked with just the
yep you gotta update your idea the butt
naked dude you're thinking about
your idea of egyptians you know they're
modern people these days
it's like you don't have to use a pe you
can use a paddle you don't have to use a
stick and he's like what's that
and they dock right at the pyramids he
doesn't have a basket man
he doesn't have a basket dude i used to
sterilize these they're called
laryngoscope
laryngoscopes what's a laryngoscope do
so this one
this part is a lamp and then this part
it's
it's like it goes into your throat and
but it has a light attached to it so
then like once you stick it in there
that's how they intubate they use this
wow so it's a light it's a it doesn't
spread open so you can yeah so it's like
spreading
your your your [ __ ] throat i forgot i
forgot work that's crazy man why would
you put a [ __ ] fish in your mouth
if you're not eating i know right i'm so
glad you left nursing so that there's
more
lorithoscopes that aren't being
sterilized right now tiff thanks i feel
like once you start
feeling it wiggle and start going down
like chomp you know like bite down so it
doesn't go down your throat but he's too
busy trying to catch the other one well
the length is this long right it looks
like it's this long
so by the time the head is about this
deep you could still [ __ ] bite some
of it right okay imagine this imagine
that you're playing tug of war right
and then you're on that balance board
because he's on a boat right so now he
has those things i'm like he's probably
distracted as a [ __ ]
like he must be so good at focusing
because he's so focused on that line
that he doesn't give a [ __ ] about what's
going on
and he didn't want to let go but he did
say like he he put the fish in his mouth
biting it but it was wiggling so much it
got out of his
grip oh and that's how i went into this
he has a weak ass
now if people ask him what that mouth do
he's like and i didn't even gag one time
and people are like oh really
like what's that mouth dude there's no
throw up on this guy oh no there's not
let me show you good job oh geez imagine
those eyeballs in your mouth you guys
remember the girl in middle school who's
like who didn't have a
gag reflex and she would always brag
about it no one in my school did that
there was always one what there was
always one yes always one maybe just
saying you
don't have a gag reflex like you're a
part of the school
you're in a 90s sitcom yeah i really was
yeah would they get root beer bottles
and show you
they uh there was one girl who did that
kind of thing yes quite quite often with
water bottles wow
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] as a demonstration
wow yeah that's impressive whack that's
a good calling
there's always one nice nice that's cool
is that a good way to get a boyfriend oh
yeah well not for long
yeah but maybe in the short term yeah
yeah she was a super spreader if you
will
a super spreader oh i get it oh and
that's a myocardium
i i miss my old you want to go back a
little bit just a little bit
that's cool just a little bit i think
you just got fired right now
what's the part that makes you want to
go back i just missed learning about the
instruments
oh i really liked learning about what
they did like in surgery
i miss my old friends at work that's it
no that's the part that i
never missed i hated the politics of the
hospital
it was so stupid there was always
politics but if you have friends
it was worse than than the [ __ ] in
high school
no i was the youngest so so you didn't
have friends
i mean i did but my the second youngest
person in my department was like 45.
wow and i was 18. i was 19.
you couldn't relate to anyone that's why
i hated working at highrise because it
was all about cya like cover your ass at
all times and like if you throw somebody
else under the bus
just to protect yourself that's even
better they get off on that [ __ ]
really yeah yeah that's the corporate
world yeah corporate world is [ __ ]
like that
when you were cleaning it in the
instruments where you're like this is
gonna save someone's life
no i didn't think about that you're like
this is just nasty
no not even that i'm like cool this is a
[ __ ]
body part that's crazy yeah i don't know
i just was really fascinated by like
the weird the underscience nasty human
part because i have my science head on
if i
if i didn't have my science hat on it'd
be disgusting i just saw that [ __ ]
randomly i'm like oh what the [ __ ] is
that
because there's like teeth and [ __ ] yeah
it's [ __ ] weird well also if you saw
it randomly in the wild that would be
crazy
you just had a restaurant look there's a
finger no
oh i did assist in a finger surgery
though that was cool when you say finger
surgery you fixed one or one came off
no uh well i didn't fix anything i
insisted but um
no so i talked about this a lot of times
but this dude he was moving a
refrigerator
and it landed on his middle finger and
so his bones
shattered like like glass it was just
like a [ __ ] ton of like tiny little bone
pieces
and it was in the middle of the night
when i was working the the night shift
and my friend he was a circulating nurse
in or it's like the search so it's like
he's running
the [ __ ] and this guy's like 65 no he
was actually young he had just became a
nurse
and um yeah he was like 30s i don't know
but anyway so he allowed me to scrub in
because i wanted to be
part of the surgery department and so he
was like cool scrub in
and i was like oh my god this is so cool
i'm gonna be in surgery so then i get in
there
and then he just had me like hold a
little retractor so like move
like the doctor put it in he moved the
skin and he's like just hold it
so i just held it the guy is out though
right oh yeah yeah
oh yeah he's completely out he's he's
under general anesthesia i thought he
was like
awake he's like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] doing it no no no no no
i want to help somebody that got shot
because i just bought an emergency
bullet wound kit oh sick
and um i want to use it what happens
with that like what's in that
so they have a a plug thing
yeah so it's like a tampon yeah you put
it inside the
uh the shot is it like a gel thing i
don't know because i haven't opened it
everything's brand new before you just
put like the gun powder
back in the day you just put a little
gun powder in there
you know no you light it don't they like
that [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh that's crazy so
somebody gets stuck i'm bleeding yeah
somebody gets shot they have to wait for
you to take the plastic off of this
thing
yep i have to take it off i have to read
the instructions
right chill out bro hold on i got you i
got you yeah this book's like 30 pages
oh my god damn
all right i don't know where to do okay
yeah then you plug it in
and then you get like a trinket or
whatever you gotta tie up the blood area
patch it up and is the is the mushroom
farming business that crazy
yes we got enemies you can't you can't
just stuff a mushroom in there
oh that might be a perfect you get the
mushroom stem yeah just put it right in
plug it in and then you also grow a
mushroom at the end
i'll be kind of sick and then you have
spores in your body yeah you can grow
mushrooms and others then they'll be
nutting everywhere
all over you not inside your body i got
the kit because um
right after right during quarantine you
know how everyone thought remember when
we saw those tanks
oh yeah all over l.a that's scary yeah
people thought like
what the [ __ ] is gonna go down right
like riots and all this stuff
and everyone's military friend said
martial law is coming but it never came
yeah right
it looked like it yeah i know like
that's so crazy
so yeah i was like alright well [ __ ] if
i get shot um
i don't know if the hospital is gonna
work so i just bought it smart
so yeah but i don't know how to use it
yet yeah you might need to watch some
youtube videos
i want practice and help somebody first
so that if someone does actually get
shot
then i can use it so maybe i'll just
wait at the hospital one day and be like
hey are you shot
there you go you want to save some money
yeah i want to say i got this little
thing i got on amazon like maybe i could
how many times can you use that kit once
[ __ ] you gotta buy another one i don't
know like 20 what if you got shot twice
well i'm [ __ ] then maybe there's extra
parts i don't know but there's cotton
swabs or whatever
we can use that toilet paper yeah we'll
we'll make it work there's the toilet
paper shortage never mind
yeah no there still is by the way yeah i
know i tried buying some
i couldn't there's no toilet paper
started again again the toilet paper
shoulders yeah
you